where's the Gratitude I've given you an
amazing life I made you
I mean was this a soap opera
[Music]
I wanted to yeah you should call one of
your easier women Roxanne from the
coffee shop Julia from the I'm sorry I
literally forgot all their names Julia
from the dry cleaners sorry
I really get the giggles on it Maya if
you can't tell the ones we actually have
I'm gonna have
yeah if you can't sell the ones we
actually have I'm gonna have to some
Maya if you can't find them oh
sorry guys tongue tied
[Music]
Linda does the Beanie Baby collector's
radio update on ygn WGN
ition
ow I have like four bloops now okay I
told my sick daughters I'd be back as
quick as I could then I waited here for
longer than
if I could raise one eyebrow do it right
now
I look I'm a hectic business
we're gonna go again you're one in a
million Robbie Jones
no one's ever calling that are we at the
hotel it was a short drive maybe they
call it cut we can we do need the radio
actually on genius is one percent
inspiration 99
yeah
I got lost
I won't do the hair thing it's too real
I love you in recession it's a great
show
[Music]
you know what you want Taney weenie
Beanie Baby we are just two pretty
ladies
[Laughter]